i've been listening to my dad's story
today i'm gonna do a reaction video on
what i think is the most embarrassing
story that he tells about me i got an
ipad for a gift
and i didn't know how to set it up so i
gave it to him
and i go man will you set this up for me
i don't know how to do it
and he brings it back later and he goes
here you go dad i'll sit up first of all
i don't talk like this or laugh like oh
just so you know your ipad is the cloud
everything from everybody's devices goes
to your ipad everybody hearing that
everything from everybody's devices
my ipad
probably should have gone to my phone to
turn off the icloud sharing everything
on my phone ends up on his ipad as a man
when you're
sitting on your own bed looking at your
own ipad looking at your pictures you
never want this sentence to leave your
mouth
well that's not my dick
i give him that one you never want to go
through your phone or your ipad or any
of your stuff and see somebody else's
dick big red flag at first i thought
somebody was sending my wife dick pics
that i had that one beat that's a lot i
wasn't even going to say anything to her
you know what i mean i was going to be
like keep looking at that skinny dick
babe i feel pretty good about myself
it's not going to be as funny when i
come out of the shower doing the
helicopter tomorrow is it is it never an
image you want your father to put in
your head helicopter ahead of the coptic
the ikea desk that i had built for my
son behind the dick and i was like
oh my god i built that desk and that
dick it's weird enough as is that my dad
for a living tells dick jokes and just
talks about dicks it's even weirder when
the dick he's talking about is yours not
a fun situation he's sending people 10
pics
just for the record not unsolicited
pictures those were asked for so i go
down into his room i'm like hey man he
goes yeah you all explain to me again
how the cloud works and he was like oh
you're so stupid
and i was like yeah no
we'll see that's the biggest irony in
this though is at the beginning i'm like
god why is he's the stupidest person of
all time and then me making this
specific mistake makes me look like
the dumbest person of all time i said
break it down for me real slow if you
can he goes okay dad
you take a picture on your phone and it
goes to your ipad i'm like what else he
was like
mom takes a picture on her phone and it
goes to the ipad
i'm like what else he's like
i take a picture on my phone and oh no
light bulb i might be screwed not only
were there pictures of me on there but
there's also like you know at the time
illegal activities that's when my mind
starts to panic
i hate when he's on stage and he
imitates me he puts his hands on his
hips he goes hands on hips like this and
when he talks about my sister he puts
his thumbs in his armpits i don't know
what that is why are you doing that hey
can i see that ipad
and i said no no not yet he goes oh okay
i don't care if he sees it you know it's
my dad it is whatever but i thought
crossed my mind of did my mom see that
photo
and then he goes
so
how's your day going
i have no idea at this point what the
[ __ ] i'm gonna say to cover my tracks
so
how's your day going
i said earlier today not great right now
i'm having a [ __ ] time in my life
and he's living his best life in this
moment
that's good dad because you know when
you're in a good mood we're all in a
good mood so
well
thanks for stopping by
he was just
sitting there toying with me man
and so i'm just trying to shoo him out
of the room so that
maybe if he comes back in an hour or two
i have a list of lies that i've already
written down and a script that i've gone
over so that i can get out
of whatever situation this is about to
turn into so i think i'm gonna stick
around for a little bit and he goes oh
okay
what a treat
and he said so
did you have a question you wanted to
ask it
and i said did you have a question you
wanted to ask me
and he goes oh sure i'll go first i have
no move to play right now but i'm not
going to come out and say something
because if i say the thing that he
doesn't know and i say something else
well i'm in a pile of [ __ ] for two
different things but he's also playing
the same game because he's seen whatever
i have on my phone and he knows there's
a couple things
that i could say and so he's waiting for
me to jump into it and i said did you
have a question you wanted to ask me
and he goes oh sure i'll go first and i
was girlfriend's name is ashley right he
goes
oh
were there are there any pictures of
ashley's boobs on
there it is what i was worried about the
most i'm his son if he sees what he sees
and fine but
there's no point in time
that
i want to unintentionally embarrass my
girlfriend by having my dad see that
jacob are there pictures of a naked
underage girl on my ipad
and he goes well not if you didn't see
him there aren't no
i go no dude it's this and he goes oh
that's just my dick i go i know what it
is man i gotta be honest him seeing my
dick was not the thing i was worried
about the most like that was the last
thing on my list he said i'm so glad you
saw that what do you think about that
angle i go no no no
we're close we're not checking each
other's dick pics close like that's not
what's going down no matter how close i
am with my dad or anybody is with their
parent
he's probably right you're never close
enough with your father to check each
other's dick out finally i had to tell
him look
don't send dick pics the penis does not
photograph well i beg to disagree based
on the photos i've sent i've got nothing
but positive feedback so i mean
i told him
nobody has ever looked at a picture of a
dick and been like
i love this picture
also we'll disagree because that is also
some feedback that i've gotten before
emperor
and i told him i think i i know how you
think women react when they get a
picture of your dick it's how you react
when you get a boob on their phone when
a teenage boy gets a boob on his phone
they lose their mind there have been a
couple times when i've just heard this
from the living room yes
had he gotten that same photo and he was
in the living room and gotten it from
his wife which i don't want to think
about whatsoever but i am for the sake
of this here i would have heard the same
thing of yes that's not just a teenage
guy thing that is a simple guy thing
guys like
they do the titty boobs the whole thing
that is not how you women react when you
get a picture of a dick right
just so you know when a woman gets a
dick pic she goes like this
followed by this stacy
only if it's small
cause she has showed your dick to
everybody
and tomorrow it's gonna be on snapchat
with doll years come to my party it
would explain why after i sent that
photo i had a couple other girls ask me
the same thing so i mean
again she's only laughing if it's small
dude or if it's unsolicited don't do
that thank you guys so much for watching
i hope you all enjoyed for more stupid
stories about me and my life growing up
and anything along those lines go ahead
and hit the like button hit the
subscribe button and hit that little
bell notification so you guys know when
new content is posted and don't forget
my dad and i are just dropping a new
podcast called hey man it's out right
now make sure you check it out it's a
whole bunch of fun we'll see you guys on
the next one